hey babe i'm coming to your town to do
stand up chrisdcomedy.com
we got boston philadelphia eatontown new
jersey pittsburgh pennsylvania waukegan
illinois nashville tennessee
i'm coming this summer all the way
through october chris
d comedy go get tickets now
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe
[Music]
hey babe hey babe i said my
african-american friends don't dance we
just pull up the pants and
do the rock away and hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
what's up babe how you doing babe you
going doing good yeah i'm doing a big uh
shirt yeah yeah nothing else yeah no no
it's all good
i um i uh yeah dude i
you ever tell you about the time i went
to the mentalist
we mean the mentalist mentalist or the
man there was a mentalist in my
in my college yeah well you didn't tell
me and i actually have mentalist
go ahead go you have a mental story well
i've i've i've seen mentalists perform
you've seen okay yeah yeah because i
just zoomed
i just did go i just did two zoom
mentalist shows
you just did two zoom mental shows in
the last month i have zoomed with two
mentalists
interesting antichrist dan white is this
magician he's well known he's the show
he does the show at the time
through the show you know what i want me
to do i was
mind blown he did a sequel to that on
zoom
i just did it he'll hear from home from
the comforts of my own home
and it was unbelievable it was really
good and then
last night last night
i i was invited to that i bought a
ticket for right
my friend told me he did it at home it
was just great do it
and i did it it was great then last
night a friend of mine
who uh is in the uh who invited me to a
private gathering
of of another mentalist named jason
saran if i'm getting his name
jason saran wrap suggestions or jason
saran saran said yeah whatever
will be and uh he did this thing his
show was called reconnected
okay and he just did it for like friends
and stuff and it was an intimate little
thing
and it literally what happened i have no
balls they got blown off again blown off
yeah what happened
well i don't know if i should give a lot
of it away but like
yeah but you're not giving away the
secret do you remember by the way when i
went with you to the nomad theater
and i walked up to the magician after
the show and i was like hey i met you a
month or two ago
i was on a radio show and the guy at the
radio show is messing up all your tricks
and i know how you do one of those card
tricks great show tonight
and he was like he was so nice and
slowly shook my hand that guy probably
hates me he was like we were saying
hello he was he was greeting everyone
goodbye which is a nice thing to do
and then uh you were like oh and it just
kind of came out because that that was
the
thing you had in common with them and
then afterwards you're like i don't know
if i should have mentioned that yeah it
was innocent on my part but after
when we were walking down the stairs and
you were like why'd you tell him that i
was a guy
as i was talking i was like ah this is
stupid a boy yeah you were like hey you
remember you
on uh the radio show and you're trick
messed up i was there to witness that
right and he was like oh thank you yeah
we should come come come again yeah come
again i love you
yeah so what happened with your
mentalist uh well that show was
shout out dan white by the way that
shows tremendous and if it's still going
because it's a hard ticket to get go
online look up dan white
i need to go see him at the no matter
see a zoom show because i mean
just just fantastic and this is dan
white not
white dan white dan is a guy that sells
drugs in my neighborhood yeah
that's not that guy we're talking about
dan white the mentalist not the magician
and i think they all know each other i
think all the points i think it's a
tight-knit community and they all like
help produce each other's
tricks and and things like that it could
be speaking out of turn but this guy's
name was jason
another really they all know each other
if they had a crew if we were all
mentalists
yeah in a crew we would call our group
the mentalist institution
yes that's nice i think menthol is okay
it was all right
it was not a home run but uh last night
they were i don't i don't know if i i
just don't know if i'm supposed to give
away but what are you giving away if
like
also guys what's a mentalist i don't get
it a mentalist
i don't know yeah what's your scene a
mentalist and a magician mentos can read
your mind quote-unquote
it says mentalists are performing
artists or entertainers who appear to be
psychic
and demonstrate highly developed mental
or intuitive feats
such as telepathy telekinesis and mind
reading so is the long island medium
really the long elementalist
is a medium mentalist i don't know it's
a different name if you're the long
island mentalist versus long island
media it's different
i played a medium on a television show
they put me in front of on stage
uh sold out show of like 150 200 people
whatever it was they put me on stage for
an hour and five minutes i pretended to
be a
a medium did you just get oh medium
talks to the dead
from through dead to you that's what
that's got it i was on stage and
they told me that they were gonna tell
me what to say in my ear and when i
walked on stage
they were like hey guess what and i
heard just static
and and i heard shh they pulled the plug
as i walked out in the curtains open it
was a hundred people and i had to give
an
hour i was i'll never forget 65 minutes
i was on stage pretending to be a medium
and i actually kept people in the in the
whole time what did you do like what
were your little
i was so nervous and i was throwing out
very broad terms
and like sometimes people weren't even
answering me yeah like i was just like
oh i'm looking you know for a name with
an m you know i i did that stuff but
then i was
had to commit to something i'd be like
i'm seeing a ring someone lost a ring
something about a ring anything anything
about a ring with anyone here something
just think real hard because it's not me
it's you someone lost the ring
something has to do with a ring and then
eventually like in like like a minute of
that i was like
flop sweating someone's like i kind of
thought i had like that's
it that's right that's right i i would
then i got everything wrong
no joke dude i got everything wrong for
like 60 minutes
people were like i think they were
getting amused
i don't know what it was bad but then i
called up a woman on stage
and i go let me ask you a question
single mother one child she goes yeah i
go nailed it
and that i loved it after i got every
single thing right you gotta go favorite
colors pink she goes yeah i go this is
what i do this is what i do
yeah i just got lucky and i got so
confident
like i guess all right everybody's like
wrong for 60 minutes i'm like single
mother loves pink has one child she goes
yeah i go
what do you guys want what do you guys
want yeah it's amazing but this guy last
night
i don't want to give anything away but
but you're doing this over zoom
yeah but how does it how does like if
someone's gonna do the show
i guess it would still be as amazing
maybe he wants me to promote like not
maybe he wants people to promote it well
you're not even saying that you you
haven't even said the name
maybe beep is i don't know i wanted to
get i wanted to get the
oh we did say the name yeah yeah yeah
yeah so anyway so all right like one of
the main tricks that blew my mind
yeah i'm not saying what the trick is i
just don't know and then go hopefully
this is not a nice thing for me to talk
about it
uh it's either there so we get sued
whatever tells a woman to write down
four cities on a piece of paper in
opposite corners right okay and then we
had these pendulums that we made it was
anything you could just you had to make
the pendulums
i actually had a pendulum from my from
my previous
mentalist show believe it or not yes
they sent a pendulum and i had my own
but you could make one by just hanging
like a ring
off a piece of string it just needs to
be a little something weighted on a
piece of string or even a
floss it was very easy okay so so before
both shows that before he makes you
watch a video to just tell you that you
need to pendulum
okay so it's like a one minute video so
it's just him and he's just like hey
guys if you're joining me tonight
i just need to have a pen and paper and
a pendulum and you can make a pendulum
very simply by taking a ring and put it
in a piece of string
simple stuff right and we're like okay
and that's the video you watch that was
it
so it comes the time lady won't raise
their hand he says
pick four cities right and write them in
the corner of pieces of paper
put an x in the middle of paper now hold
the pendulum
as steady as possible above the x as
steady as possible do not move your hand
stay as frozen as you can and the lady
was like this and then all of a sudden
the pendulum started moving even though
she wasn't moving it
and it started swinging to one corner of
the four random cities that she wrote
down so he's like
are you moving the thing she's like no
he goes is he clearly going to one of
the corners she's like yes
he's like uh is it a place you you you
want to go to is that what it is she
goes
actually i've always really wanted to go
there right and he goes and what is it
and it was uh um
bozeman montana okay does that sound
like a place bozeman montana bozeman
montana yeah yeah but it was she goes
bozeman montana very i mean bozeman
montana
random one i would have wrote like
tahiti you know like hong kong i don't
know bozeman montana
so she's like yeah i actually really
i've always wanted to go that i can't
believe it gravitated to that
because that's what i wanted to go to
more than any place else and he's like
that's amazing
right and then he goes hey did you watch
my video because you had the pendulum
she goes yeah he goes
uh everybody go pull up your videos that
he sent out by the way
earlier in the day and he's in his
kitchen and behind him on the
fridge was all you know those magnet
letters that you give to kids where they
spell
all the different colors yeah it was
just letters from his i guess
he has a kid maybe he doesn't it was
just a prop but the whole fridge was
there from the video he sent earlier
and in the middle of those things it
said
pick and then bozeman
wow so she saw that video
i guess what we're assuming is that she
saw the video
and it subconsciously got in her head
and she wrote it and it came out
but the video is from hours before which
is wild
wild and then another guy right that's
insane
i know it's it's wild right because what
if because that may not work all the
time i
i don't i i don't understand what
happens when it doesn't work and i hope
i'm not giving anything away
but anyway another thing is a guy he
asked another guy and i won't say the
specifics on air
but he asked another guy to open up
wikipedia
right and then he said like uh go to any
article google anyone
and then he said pick a name a word on
that page
think of it in your head and then he
wrote it turned around it was the words
the guy was thinking of and then he said
pick a celebrity alive or dead
throughout history right now forever
and and the guy did it and then the guy
the person chose
he goes go back to the video i sent you
this afternoon so he pulls it up on a
shared screen he goes back to the video
he zooms in on the right of the fridge
there's a little pad
and there's a piece of paper hanging off
of it and it says the name
of the person in the video he sent us
earlier in the day
the name of the person that that guy
chose randomly and looked up
the guy was having a full-blown
conniption fit
i was like i can't believe this i could
have shown that the guy was freaking out
it was the craziest thing ever dude
jesus christ
yeah it was it was it was like it was
like wow this is this is the most insane
thing i've ever seen
because stuff like that because with the
bozeman thing i'm like
could they have edited the video could
he have like a helper that's making it
then
but you're saying it was like the same
link to the video that you always had
yes everybody just missed it how about
this are you ready for this
no but let's do it i don't want to give
it away give it away give it away give
it away now
okay at the end of the show he told us
to go
check something that happened not the
video something else
that happened when the show first
started
and i i don't know how to do this
without giving it away i don't want to
give it away on the guy
the most insane thing ever though was
that he
somehow before the show started
wrote what was going to happen in the
show who he was going to speak to what
they were going to guess
and and that all happened and then the
thing that we went to look at
was time stamp so you know that it
didn't happen after the show and he
wrote
predicted what was going to happen in
the show and it all happened now granted
i know this is
a trick but i don't i can't even figure
out how he pulled the trick off
i i feel bad i don't want to give him i
mean we just want to know i mean
i i don't i personally have no magician
law i don't know
i don't know what the law because my
whole thing is he's probably created a
show that's only going to work on zoom
right once the world opens up they're
not going to go see that show live
you know he's doing zoom tricks i mean i
do have a question do you believe
it's he's like a kind of pseudo con man
or he's like some kind of oh no
he's an entertainer i don't think he's a
comment i'm sure there's people that use
this type of thing to trick people
but this is just a you know magician
kind of entertainment kind of guy and
he's great at it
i don't know how he did it i don't think
he has any abilities but
i just i want him to say it all right
beep just
ah i can't i can't say it i don't want
to ruin it for the guy
but how do you know it's ruining for the
guy you don't even know the tricks how
do you know
but don't you think everybody goes and
tells their friends
exactly the whole show and then say you
got to see this guy and then they'll go
see that guy it has to be a different
thing
what about the guy with dan white when
he was when he made that he pulled that
girl up on stage and
he pointed to the exact word out of
these million words that she could have
picked he picked it and he had it
circled with his ass and whatever he
went crazy
we told everybody what happened and he
probably did it again the next night
that's true
so just tell the tricks okay this is
this we're getting behind
we're getting behind the curtain okay
the show started at like seven o'clock
you guessed anything exactly about you
that came true and you weren't in on it
uh he called on me and i messed it up oh
yeah
what'd you do well because i i just
he he gave specific instructions and i
didn't do something right and i was like
the guy on the zoom and messed it up
i didn't mess up his trick but he's like
no i can't do with you i got to do with
someone else and i was like oh sorry
you never gave up your address i don't
know what would they be
would the doorman just you know let
somebody up with a red balloon right
no no yeah i don't know but it was
unbelievable it was unbelievable
and he he did he did some other crazy
things too man he did stuff that blew me
away
he okay he had someone who's he's
saran saran or white dan danny dubs okay
dan white did another amazing thing okay
he he tells a guy to call he tells a
random guy
google restaurants near you right okay
the guy google's a restaurant
he shows that he goes this is the three
closest name he goes pick the one
closest he goes all right
uh all right he goes what's the number
dan why calls the guy he goes pick a
number between 1 and 500 or whatever you
said
the guy's like what we're closing who is
this because just pick a number
the guy picks a number right you think
it's you don't know where it's going
after that he says you know they mail
those packages to the house that's where
i got my pendulum
and he goes some of you have a book oh
no he goes
he goes i send some of you a dictionary
then he tells someone else
pika he goes rip up one page out of the
dictionary
and sit on it he tells give it the book
to your husband or something i might be
messing this up
give the book to us but he's going to
rip out one page in a dictionary give it
you sit on don't ever get up for the
rest of the show
right and then later the guy from the
pizzeria picks a number between like one
of five hundred he tells the girl
to get up off her ass flip to the book
and see what page is missing and it's
the page of the number the guy from the
pizza
oh it was saying it was the wildest
thing i i
i may have messed up the intricacies of
it but it was something to that effect
and it was just mind-blowing i'm so how
do people not break their computers like
if that happened
i would have smashed my macbook into a
fit of rage yeah spike it
it's unbelievable what he did wait so he
so damn white is doing shows like you
can go buy tickets for dan martin now on
zoom
yes that's amazing if he's still doing
him yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh wow dude yeah no the people that
scene
see because like you know it's all
illusions right it's not it's magic but
it's like this illusion and i can
understand
i get fascinated just as much with
trying to understand how they pull the
illusion
well i can understand some way and not
that i can understand but like
when someone is in when you're in the
room with someone there's a lot of
slider handles things you could do
but on zoom how are you doing this on
zoom
like the way that the mentalists are
able to adapt yeah like how did dan
white just adapt to it
and it was a really professional show
had music lighting he was in a studio
had camera work
it was it was it was it was like a crazy
it was like i was living in the future
we felt like we were watching the show
that we watched in the theater it was
really really really cool
well it says is there any like illusion
behind the scenes like do we have any
things like that they've uncovered like
how they might be able to
keep searching around it says like they
make you think what
they want you to think i don't get it
the illusion is that
the illusion is that it is not mind
reading but rather mind whispering
they create the illusion that they are
reading your mind but most of the time
they just tricked your mind into
thinking what they want you to think
yeah but how did he but how does he
trick someone how does he know what page
she's gonna i i mean obviously in some
way but i i
i mean we had a zoom i went and i knew
people that did it right and we all
zoomed afterward and just like we're
talking
theories on how he did it nobody had
like an hour blown off
but no one had balls they all got blown
off 100
dude my ball i remember i remember
weighing in two pounds lighter the day
after we saw dan white because my balls
i had no balls
must be working but it's oh but then i
grew back and then you know something i
do uh this is a fun thing that you can
do do you ever do you ever like do jokes
just for yourself
oh all the time all the time so you do
something that's
you're the only one witnessing it or
seeing it you laugh and it's for you and
that's where it stays
yep okay okay so i do that a lot too one
of the things i do and i've done it for
like a long time and
it became a habit and then joe and i
started competing when we go to a
restaurant
if i'm at any restaurant that's like
like just slightly
nice you know just any any kind of
upscale or medium skill to above
restaurant
on the way out as i'm walking to the
door i just lean in right behind
someone's ear
at like a table on the way to the door
and i go try the jalapeno poppers that
blow your balls off
and i don't wait for them to answer i
just keep walking around keep walking
and i just turn back and usually there's
an array of different reactions that
happen yeah sometimes they're confused
sometimes they're angry sometimes the
whole table just starts like slamming
like yeah but now then we
kept doing it now we like we try to
outdo each other right so now i'll just
go like and i'll just be like
now we just lead with excuse me i have
literally i have no no testicles
yeah and i'd be like what i'd be like
they got blown off because i tried the
jalapeno papa's getting around for the
table and i just walked out
it's so much fun do that i said it's
like my gift to you guys
it's just fun when you're at a
restaurant when you're walking out your
coats on people are eating just lean get
in too close to comfort
don't too close for comfort don't let
them even see you coming and go excuse
me try to help on your papas to pull
your balls off
people are just like what sometimes
people are just like should we get the
poppers
you know what i do sometimes when i'm
and i still do it and i should probably
stop
anytime i'm leaving a tip on a credit
card i'll put a piece of food
over the tip and just watch the waiter
waitress have to move the piece of food
and see how much tip they got
that's so and i never tell anyone and i
just watched
i just let my family i'm like oh let me
warm up the car for you guys and then i
just watch her move a piece of lettuce
or him move a piece of lettuce
you know we did some um buddy on my show
mar for like a decade
uh anytime that he would he would pay
his bill like other times it'll be like
four checks or if we pay for each other
whatever it was
when he got the bill he would always
just sign and like he would never he
would never look he'd get up to
he just was always left it unattended
right so whenever he's like
for any time that he got up and ordered
and then wasn't looking or got to go to
the bathroom
he would sign his thing put his tip in
and then get up
right and every time he did that we
opened it back up and added like a one
in front of the number or like a zero at
the end of the number
so because he did he he would always
break about how he just doesn't all his
bills are on auto pay
he never works because i used to like up
until like a week ago i would put stamps
and envelopes for all my bills right
he was always making fun of me and he's
like what are you doing simplify your
life i don't even look at my
uh i don't do any accounting whatsoever
i don't balance it checkbook what are
you nuts
and i was like so we all started so he
would get up if he would leave like you
know
i don't know like eight dollars we made
it 18. right if he would leave like you
know five dollars we made it 50.
and we and we had a game where we would
tally
how much we cost him extra right and
that would go in our bank and we were
trying to see who could cost him the
most money over time right and then one
time he caught one of us doing it
and he freaked and then he was like he
thought it was funny but then it hit him
at once he's like have you done this
before i'm like yeah he goes how many
times have you done this and we're like
we have done it every physical possible
time we could in the last 10 years
yeah we might have cost him thousands of
dollars yeah yeah was he mad or he just
didn't care i mean at that point what
are you gonna do we don't know the
dollar amount
what's gone is gone what happened has
happened you got to just say
good job good job it's a great job yeah
it's a great job wow dude yeah i mean
i do that to your friends i give you
that too 100 do it to your friends and
see and you
make sure they don't own a gun they tell
you what my buddy did to me on a bad
santa christmas
dinner no i have like a tradition we do
like a fun life
you always have you have like fun
festive things like a bad sign of
christmas dinner
you always have like a certain type of
party yeah i like it you gotta
i got no i think you do great yeah yeah
so we have an annual we have this annual
party where we go out for chinese food
we're like the same 15 people no joke i
think it's like our 12th year or
something like that did you miss it
for the the panda like no joke dude that
long first year
but you know we did we all then mode my
friend jay
shout out to jay miller shout out to my
friend jay he a heads up
he usually take control of booking the
reservation and every year and all that
stuff
and um we he made it we all venmo him
money
and he went to the restaurant and gave
the weight of the money anyway oh nice
yeah yeah because he was going to miss
out that year yeah but we do the thing
where we all pick out of a hat
and it's a bad gift so after the
dinner's over everyone gets their gifts
on the table
and we start and we go who did you get
and then we go around the table and
everyone stands up
says who they got says a little
something about the person and then they
give them the gift and they open up in
front of everybody right it's just
really fun like we've gotten
everything from like like once someone
gave someone a cat
and they like an actual live cat this
day they have the cat
yeah they like he gave them a pet like
he gets it gets intense right
and one of my friends her she's she was
divorced but her wedding album
like in back in the day they used to
spend like a grand on a wedding album
and the and the pages were like thick
cardboard and it was like pressed onto
the page
like that big book right she she in the
first year she gave the wedding album
and then someone regurgitated it we gave
it every
and for 12 years someone has got her
wedding album and the thing is you get
it you have to save it
okay there's two there's two gifts like
that that go around that have been there
on forever somebody gave someone a
budded role uh the first year in tin
foil that role we have
it's 12 years later we have the same
role so what is it just in uh just it's
rolling tin foil in a ziploc bag
people just when you get it you put it
in your freezer you keep in your freezer
for one year and then you give the roll
to somebody else it's amazing
so my buddy joe embergio shout out to
him
he writes on my show he's my good body
musician does a lot of music for the
show
he this mother effer had me and
he somehow gets my wallet i didn't know
this
steals my credit card the when it's time
to pay the bill before we do the gifting
ceremony
he get excuse himself in the bathroom
goes to the front gets the check
pays the bill with my credit card gets
it printed out
puts it in the leather jacket wraps it
in in gift paper
and then sits back down when i turn to
go he gives it i open it it's the
checkbook
with my card with it it was 650 dollars
he ran my card and then it said uh merry
christmas i gave you the gift of giving
[Laughter]
were you mad at them for you was just
like that's all right it's kind of like
what murray is
really funny yeah i said touche you son
of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] he freaking
tip nailed you nailed me i
and you said for your new for your
christmas dish it's always chinese food
yeah i've just started eating chinese
food
just started no really i swear to god
yeah so the place we go is this real
cool place it's a
time capsule in staten island it's by
the mall it's called jade island
okay it's um like a tiki like pan asian
like uh
it's like this real like kitschy place
where you can get like uh
you know zombie drinks with umbrellas
and you sit in these little boots that
are huts and stuff
it's like a staten island institution
right so it's chinese food so yeah so
that's where we go every year shout out
to
shout out jade island sent out jane
island yeah just started eating chinese
food for the first time in my life i've
been eating shrimp at lobster sauce
that's what i got shrimp lobsters and
rice what made you
why did you never eat chinese food prior
i don't um
i don't know it just wasn't part of my
cuisine at all and i would be like
cuisine
is it not is chinese food what's what
makes a cuisine
what what makes chinese food cuisine
yeah cuisine i mean
cuisine
[Laughter]
what am i saying wrong no it's not
chinese cuisine
like cuisine you're saying cuisine
chinese cuisine
chinese what am i am i saying the word
wrong cuisine
cuisine cuisine cuisine cuisine
chinese cuisine yes cuisine it's chinese
cuisine it's cuisine yeah so it's
italian it's not italian
uis you're saying like you're a cous
like who's hound who's having it
you're saying cuisine like ceo it's
cuisine
cuisine no it's not cuisine it's cuisine
chinese like quiz show chinese
quiz cuisine
why did you never eat i mean cuisine is
did you never funnier yeah i don't know
it's just not so it's just
my family would always have pizza or
we'd get you know food from a diner but
you never had like
pork fried rice or bread first pork chop
was on the last episode beef broccoli
beef and broccoli i've never had a girl
i never will have i've had wonton soup
but but i asked you if you had a
handkerchief i went egg roll you went
yes i have had it one time
oh yeah an egg roll is i think one of
the most underrated things in the world
an egg roll is not as good but an egg
roll i think
is so god damn good that if you i always
want to eat more than one egg roll
i've never eaten more than two but i
want to eat five well like chinese if
you had if you could pick chinese food
or pizza
are you always going to go pizza over
chinese food well pizza is like i mean
really pizzas are hard to beat pizza's
like
yeah the ultimate right but are you a
chinese food guy pimp
you know it's a food i've never had in
my life and i will eat it on the show if
you want to
indian food i've never in my life had
indian food yeah it's it's uh
do you like spices do you like curry
yeah if you don't it's it's hard to uh
that's a that's pretty predominant in a
lot of the cookies because at least in
new york anytime i go
past an indian food restaurant nobody's
ever in there
you know what i mean that's a seinfeld
episode by the way really yeah babubat
what a very very good man very bad man
it's it's a whole thing this
this really sweet indian guy opens up i
think no one goes there so jerry starts
going there
and then jerry gets a little bit of a
sense of entitlement and he has a
falling out with baboo bot
and it's this whole thing about the
cuisine but yeah you got to watch
seinfeld never seen seinfeld
i've i've seen i've another i've never
seen seinfeld i've never seen the
godfather but
i i've never even seen a second of the
godfather but seinfeld i've seen
episodes here and there i'm a little
hot because i'm wearing a flannel i
noticed you're wearing
a like a dead to rights full-on winter
coat
chrissy carharts yeah are you not dying
inside right now i'm committed to the
bit
yeah but yeah it's just it's just one of
those things where i
i ate a couple extra sweets so i'm
trying to incinerate the calories with
the car
jacket while we do the podcast you just
ate food
then you throw this heavy jacket i see
you over there you're like getting hot
yeah you're like you're like
you're fine i know i'm fading i'm fading
yeah but you know but
listen i did it to myself what did you
eat for chinese food shrimp and broccoli
oh okay i mean
yeah i pretty much had everything on a
chinese menu right you
wow this so this is a whole new world
for you are you excited i'm excited but
i i don't
i still you know even with sushi and
chinese food i just don't use the
chopsticks and i don't know how to use
the chopsticks
and i don't understand how you know
people in the asian community can just
so freely and easily use the chopsticks
for me a fork and knife and a spoon is
just a better option
you know did you ever hear that seinfeld
bit is it really science
about god great bit no but this is from
a stand-up he's like you know i got to
get a hand to the chinese people they're
really hanging out hanging in there with
the chopsticks
and this is the 30 year old bit he goes
you know they've seen the fork
he's like put it together because you
see farmers out there plowing the land
right with a pitchfork a fork right he
was they're not plowing 400 acres with a
couple of pool cues
yeah no i actually use i'm not like i
don't think i'm a chopstick professional
like karate kid when he catches the fly
right but like i
can't eat chinese food or japanese food
without using a chopstick
what is it about it like like i won't
dig into my chinese food with a fork
oh no i'm trash i can't use the
chocolate fork and knife i eat sushi
with my hands
i'll pick it up and eat it with my
fingers i i don't feel right eating
sushi or chinese food without the
chopsticks it feels like
i'm cheating or something i don't know
what do you think workers at chinese
food restaurants and sushi restaurants
when the customer asks for a fork and
knife they get very offended they're
like
f table 15. no as a matter of fact i
believe that they become accustomed to
giving out
plastic cutlery because they because i
believe that what you're saying to me is
a common issue that people have
right yeah yeah like i'm not alone in
not knowing how to use chopsticks no
no you're not alone how do you want hot
soup with a chopstick
no then i use a spoon but do the age do
chinese use a spoon as well no actually
you know what they probably do they
probably eat
eat whatever they can with and then just
tip it out of the bowl just sipping on
the ball yeah
you do you do a sake like a sake bomb
yeah it's like shots well that's a sh
the bomb is like a shot equivalent but
do you drink sake it's not filtered cold
hot it's alcohol right yeah it's like
like rice wine i'm also like a yeah i've
sake i've definitely had i've definitely
done
sake bombs yeah well that's that that's
when you're turning it up
fermented rice yeah it's a for in japan
sake is a general term for any alcoholic
beverage
and what westerners know asaki actually
refers to nina hushu
ninoshu ninanchu the tradition the
traditionally brewed and fermented drink
do you want to do an episode we call
called the sake bomb where we have like
a huge bottle of sake and by the end of
the episode we have to have finished it
thousand percent just see what happens
thousand percent of the journey takes us
and then
furthermore even add to the bit we then
go ahead if hopefully the world's open
go do comedy for a small audience and
bomb for that audience
right from here yeah we'll go we'll get
we'll get wrecked from here on sake
we'll finish the episode go right to our
spots together we'll go on the same show
we'll have pimp record it and then we'll
we'll we'll put the uh we'll put the
those saki bomb sets on the patreon
patreon i'm sick and tired of taking
vitamins and having neon green pea
well then you got to try peak babe peak
is a supplement of a vitamin c
thousand milligrams okay studies have
shown that you might absorb up to 50
percent
of vitamin c in your pee and piss it
right out this thing
bioavailable full spectrum i don't know
what that means but i know it sounds
but it is no it's maximized for
absorption that is the key
yeah yeah these it's a ready to consume
from you take this directly from the
packet i did it that's not blood
that's that's peak tea coming at you i'm
telling you right now they use
lipos now these are big words and
i'm gonna try my best let's do it
liposomal light
lipo liposomes liposomal encapsulation
technology well liposomes are made from
the same stuff as our cells
right right so that's exactly where you
need it revolutionary formula supports
your immune system it supports
cellular health right uh healthy
collagen levels and healthy aging
and whoever has this flavor i've never
seen a company as this flavor and when
you see it in a company when you see it
on the shelves you have to get it
because it goes quick
black european elderberry flavor yup you
can use this number one you can take
these on the go
throw them in your pocket your purse and
everything take it once or twice a day
it tastes good so you look forward to it
yep and the soy free liposome so we got
no soy boys over here
and if you just go to peak tea.com
that's p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a dot com
slash hey babe and use the code hey babe
at checkout you get five percent off
your first order plus free shipping when
you purchase a bundle
i'm telling you if you want your
vitamins absorbed into your body and
blood and you don't want it to hurt on
your stomach and you don't want neon
green pp
you got to go to peak tea sorry
p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com slash hey babe promo code hey
babe
check out at checkout and you get five
percent off your first order and you get
free shipping when you purchase a bundle
uh let's play peek-a-boo sorry
you know that i love cereal yeah it's
one of my top three foods right
and i couldn't eat it i had to abandon
cereal because most cereal is terrible
for you right it's just sugar
no matter what you think it just gets
out to sugar so i stopped but
uh we got a sponsor on board i tried it
and cereal is back for me it's got to be
magical magic spoon
everybody talks about magic spoon yeah i
mean everybody literally because
is it oh it's got 13 grams of protein 13
to 14 grams of protein
only four nut gram only four net grams
of carbs
and it's only a hundred and forty 140
calories a serving you have a stroke
just yes you smell toast i'm sorry
listen to me here's the part though i
lost my mind because i got excited
it's zero sugar though zero sugar zero
sugar
so and they have like chocolate they
have frosted they have fruity
uh cocoa with peanut butter which they
say tastes exactly like a peanut butter
cup
you know how you'd like have healthy
cereal and taste like oh this doesn't
taste right right somehow they made this
cereal taste like actual
cereal again yeah and then you can just
eat it and it's not bad for you it's
like
it's ridiculous i've been pounding boxes
i probably cancel out the health
benefits by eating a sleeve of four
boxes
of magic spoon every time i eat it well
listen if you go to magicspoon.com
hey babe you get a variety pack and you
get five dollars off your order but
here's what you got to do
you got to go to magicspoon.com hey babe
but also put in the promo code hey babe
don't forget to put in the promo code
hey babe after going to magicspoon.com
babe sorry
i'm just going to let sal do it i love
magic spoon remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com hey babe and use the
promo code
hey babe to save five dollars off yeah
i'm getting into the asian cuisines i'm
getting to the indian cuisines
uh well the indian cuisine i have to
still yet uh i have to get into
even though i my ancestry.com proves to
me that i'm mostly german
i do not like german food yeah german
food is heavy
and it's really out there you got to
really want to like i always feel like
german food is heart attack food
right it's like a lot of broad what do
they got pretzels
onions broth hot dogs cabbage
broth brought worse yeah cabbage i guess
a little bit there's smash is that
they rabbit too they call it haas and
pfeffer and the only reason i know that
is because in mighty ducks too
um the coach what's the coach's name
again is it franz what was the coach's
name the old man
he was like haas and fefer i forget you
never seen mighty ducks i have but it's
been since mighty ducks
by the way did you see the turtles right
emilio estevez did you see the
turnaround from goldberg the goalie
from the actor who played goldberg the
goalie on my induction
now you mean yes he was fully like on
drugs and really down on his ways like i
think he might have even been using like
heroin and crystal meth
and then got sober and you've never look
at this this is what goldberg the goalie
looked like
oh my god this is what he looked like a
year ago he's in his mid-30s he looks
like my god
looks like a 75 year old native american
man
now oh my god now now now now go do
goldberg the goalie today or whatever
yeah did he turn it around
he turned it all around look at him back
on the left he looks back like goldberg
again but look
look at how crazy that was good for him
man
great hair either way great smile even
when he was even when he was
in the midst of a drug use i mean look
how great that hair was yeah
oh that's good to hear that's really
good to hear came all the way back
that's why i brought it up because it's
a feel good story kid came all the way
back yeah but then emilio
estevez you know amelia charlie sheen
yeah that
are brothers and then their fathers
martin sheen yeah yeah right emilio
estevez i think it's charlie estevez
actually sheen is the fake name
so why didn't you want to go by estevez
that's this is a great
martin sheen is martin estevez uh uh
can we look up martin sheen maybe they
got different fathers
yeah but then how would he be charlie
estevez
martin sheen named sheen estevez his
name is martin sheed's real name is
ramon antonio gerardo estevez
whoa i wouldn't gather adam
martin looks like his name is bill smith
martin sheen plays like a retired old
irishman
in every movie and tv show and his real
name's ramon antonio gerardo estevez
i mean if that's my name that's what
that's my name i mean that's
that's a name right there yeah that's it
that's it oh my god his
initial spell rage rage
i've never seen apocalypse now that's
supposedly a great movie oh my god
yeah that's did you ever see a you know
what rage just reminded me of you ever
see um
uh dangerfield ronnie dangerfield what's
his big back to school
oh yeah did you see that no he's giving
he's giving a speech he's like rage
rage he he has um what's his name from
uh
a famous author so it goes edgar allan
poe
no no um uh kurt vonnegut okay
okay so he he has to do us he goes back
to school obviously in college
he goes to carnegie mellon and he has to
do a project on and he's rich remember i
don't even remember the movie
i vaguely remember he's got to do a
paper on kurt vonnegut
and so he he hires kurt vonnegut
to to write the paper because he's rich
and then he reads the paper
in school and he gets into a fight with
a teacher who i think he's romantically
linked to
and she goes in another thing after the
fight she goes whoever wrote that paper
doesn't know the first thing about kurt
vonnegut
ronnie you know what's fast life no he
passed away he did he died years ago
remember that and danger fields
his comedy club danger fields closed in
the midst of the pandemic and they say
it's haunted by dangerfield's ghost
wow you know how many good danger field
stories that probably are
dude do you know what's amazing what's
insane about rodney dangerfield [ __ ] he
died
60 17 years in 2004. do you know
that he did not get famous till he was
in his late 40s
same thing as morgan freeman didn't get
famous until they were in their 40s or
50s
really yeah dude no ronnie dangerfield
in his 40s
was like working a job as a salesman i
didn't know that about morgan freeman
yeah morgan freeman didn't get famously
he was 50. look at uh
rodney dangerfield's real first name
that's
jack roy yeah jack roy but born
jacob rodney cohen so jacob cohen turned
to jack roy
turned to rodney dangerfield yeah if you
had to not use your real name did you
ever think about what you would have as
like a
showbiz or fake an alias it wasn't chris
stefano like let's say you had to but
it's going to be not like to be private
but like that's your name in the public
like
that's your entertainment name um like
would you
uh ace hardware
[Laughter]
where'd you pull that from i don't know
i just go by ace hardware all right
come to the stage now ace hardware joe
gotta almost need almost named his son
ace
yeah isn't that something else that's a
that's a big big choice it's a big
choice
jasmine wanted to name our daughter
whose name is delilah she want to name
her ace lynn and i was like this is
we're not naming right
first name lin middle name ace lynn but
one name aceland
like iceland yeah like i slip yeah aslan
i was like ashlynn and she was like no
acelyn
i've never heard that name she made it
up um yeah she just made it up i was
like we're not naming her insulin
but it's a oh it's a french male name
meaning noble oh we shouldn't name her
aslan
wow
[Music]
can i have some gasoline oscillate
who's the strangest named person you've
ever met strange
i met i met a kid i went to school with
the kid
in high school i don't know if i was
talking about his podcast his name was
roy g biv
which was roy g biv is how you remember
the colors of the rainbow but his name
was roy middle name g last name biff
and his parents did it as a goof but his
name i graduated the kid named roy g biv
his last name was really biv and his
middle name was really easy he was in
his parents just went for it yes went
for it roy g biv is probably
oh and then there was two brothers who
used to play high school high school
basketball against their names were
scientific and majestic map
oh my god they're good players google's
scientific method no
way one was scientific the other one was
majestic or majestic maps scientific map
majestic mapping basketball murray went
to georgetown and his colleague one of
his next-door neighbors in the dorms was
another guy from georgetown that used to
play with um
wasn't it i don't remember
i don't remember i always loved that
name because he used to say like a
abubakar i always used to run it like
he's murray used to sell coca-cola
yeah like like like black market
coca-cola like for money
instead of the vending machine he
undercut them oh my god and
that's hilarious used to come to him to
borrow a condom and buy a coca-cola
look at this majestic map at scientific
map of march madness basketball legacy
wow yeah real brother scientific map
scientist oh what's his name
what's his what is it his name change
his name to something like that
uh ron artest yeah metal world peace
yeah meta world peace yeah yeah yeah
is he still met at world peace no he's
full he's he's fully changed his name to
matter world peace and his
that his jerseys will say world peace
world peace that's not run our tests
yeah and the people calling meta meta
world peace yeah yeah
yeah dude i um i had a little kid when i
was little i lived in these apartment
buildings
you know i ran up to the roof yeah um
there was a kid that lived in one sea i
was in 2d at the time
and once his name was rizwand i guess he
was uh you know
indian kid he was a couple of years
younger than us i was
i want to say if i was eight he was
maybe five right and rizwand
was infamous in the building in all the
buildings because rizwand used to swing
his door open
into the actual hall of the building
completely naked
shake the front jump shake his ass and
close the door again
great and any and he used to do it like
throughout the day throughout the week
throughout the months
like rizwan used to always just come out
and just shake his little thing and then
shake his ass and then slam the door
closed never be like chris want
first one we loved it yeah he loved it
yeah it wasn't like a thing you know it
was like it was funny as hell
right i don't even know i don't even
think he was really trying to be funny
i just think he didn't know any better
and he would just dance what do you mean
you don't know be able but what what do
you mean you don't know anybody it was
five so i think it was like more like
very
it was very infantile right i think he
would just like it's you know it's
wristband but we're like
shake his ass what's he doing now do we
know i mean
i don't know i mean he's now he's a 40
year old man he was just arrested for
storming the capitol
he was caught because he was shaking his
ass yeah yeah no dude
chris you know can you please tell me if
you know of any place that i can go
if i want to get a little bit of
discreet counseling
off the top of my head the number one
place that i
i'm thinking of is betterhelp.com
well what's that i gotta go to some
office no which i gotta pay outrageous
prices
nope well i got to wait two weeks to
start it nope you can do it from the
comfort of your own home
get a discreet licensed counselor
to hear whatever it is you want to talk
about
for a great price if you put in the
promo code hey babe you actually get 10
off the first month 10 percent off
american go to 10
as far as i'm as far as i know i was
told 10
american money wherever you could be in
islamabad pakistan right you're still
going to get off 10
american for the first month by going to
better help
not health better help help
calm promo code hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
10 off the first month it's just it's
the right thing to do i can't believe i
asked you that because you had
all the information i needed sal a lot
of
times i'll see you doing things and i'll
say why don't you just ask me
yeah and i'm happy that on the podcast
you decided to ask me remember that time
i was just putting a straw into an
orange and you were like you should just
pour yourself a glass of juice
yes i should defer to you more often and
where do you think because
like i was just like you how many times
did you see me
putting the straw into the orange how
did i learn
to start drinking orange juice
betterhelp.com
betterhelp.com is why i learned that you
don't have to do that it's just in the
commercial
do they stick the straw in the orange
juice you know what it makes sense
because we could all
use betterhelp dot com
backslash hey babe for 10 off who
doesn't want 10
off the first month of anything i want
10 off everything they're getting me
spoiled
yeah better help is getting me spoiled
right i storm into a room now the first
thing i say is i want 10 percent off i
want to kill where i am
yeah if they come to back to this show
and they want to advertise and say we
love your fans so much
they've been they've been supporting
betterhelp.com hey babe so much we want
to give you 20
off i'm going to say no it's going to
stay at 10.
that's right it just feels right you're
not trying to take advantage
it just feels right betterhelp.com hey
babe
so i'm sitting at home yesterday oh yep
pray tell me yeah
all of a sudden i get a knock at the
door no it's the postman post person
yeah oh i i say you say i have a package
for you
okay i said okay did you know who it's
from no idea okay i open up the package
what happened
i pulled out a t-shirt oh t-shirt i look
at the t-shirt yeah you know what
t-shirt says
ask me about my butthole what about your
butthole
it's clean the t-shirt said that
the t-shirt didn't say that you asked me
i i said ask me about my own haul and
you said what about your butthole yeah
and i said it's clean but the t-shirts
that ask me about my butthole why
because if you were to ask me if you
would ask me a week ago about my
butthole i would say it's dirty
but right now it's what happened in the
time from last week to today
when i opened up that package not only
was the t-shirt that said ask me about
my butthole
there was also a device in there and it
said hellotushi.com
and i said hello tushy.com yeah what's
going on
i thought i never said goodbye to my
tushy yeah hellotushi.com
it's a it's a type of bidet you put it
on your existing toilet it sprays water
directly into your butthole
it saves me eighty percent on toilet
paper
i'm telling you i went to go wipe my
butt yesterday after using this tushy
i said what the hell am i using you
doesn't even need the toilet paper for
me
because i for me i have the i'm the kind
of i have the kind of fecal matter where
i usually use in
one sitting i can use 80 of a roll of
toilet paper
that's how much fecal matter comes out
of my butt that is frustrating it's
frustrating yeah
yeah instead do you need electricity for
this
no electricity so it's it's ready to go
right out of the package ready to go
right out of the package
literally if i went right if i was in
islamabad pakistan right now
yeah i could have my tushy don't even
worry about if there's electricity in
the part of the town you're in worry
about it you don't have to worry about
as long as you got running water
your butthole can remain clean
some sort of revolution it's a
revolution and how many people are doing
this
millions what they even have a new one
the the 3.0 model
and what if i already have a tushie from
in the past you upgrade to the 3.0 model
guess what you got to do why go to
hellotushy.com promo code hey babe
we're going to give something we're
going to give a promo here yeah well
yeah actually go to hellotushy.com
hey babe you get 10 off plus free
shipping
hellotushy.com hey babe 10 off plus free
shipping
i tell you right now i give you my word
to get this is my word
i'm not going to go another day without
blasting water up my ass yeah i know
weird names like that i um i'm trying to
think of anybody else because i have a
bad one what do you got this
this poor asian girl i knew was named
into porn
but spelled weird i'll never she had the
longest grade school run
why would he why would their family do
that into porn
into porn yeah did you ever see the name
of that it comes
i always like i always forget it like i
remember it but i forget the name
it comes up at the beginning of every
family guy episode there was a writer or
producer on there
it's a woman and her last name is like
longer than most last names
okay and it's i every time i see it i
try to say it real fast see if i can
pronounce it
and it goes away and she's a writer it's
unmistakable the name though
it's like it's like sherry something or
other and it it the last name is like i
think it's like
20 letters go to maybe writer's pimp
see that name right there sherry sherry
wrong that's really tough to i mean we
don't have the
we don't have this like the i don't know
to me i mean most people would have to
do a double take on that name
wrong sherry
cherry there she is sherry chava prima
dupe wrong
boom um it's probably
cherry or if it's cherry or cherry do
you think it's cherry i think it's
cherry the second name also starts with
a ch maybe it's like alliteration so
it's
cherry so she probably is from i would
guess ever probably
wrong maybe from vietnam could be i i
don't know but
i mean now that you say it i could say
it oh cherry chocolate probably
cherry sherbet also known as
cherry chevra they call it cherry sheva
okay shiva so but she's from columbus
ohio
there you go tai so when times every
time the
family guy starts i always see it but it
goes so fast oh my god what was that
name
i mean executive producer of family guy
and co-executive warville you make a lot
of money honey five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
18 letters in the last name chev
uh six syllables i mean name
another oh look there's the
pronunciation you can click on it i've
never met her because i i've been on the
orville set too
uh i guess you don't know orville said
yeah why are we on the orville set
um uh pals with a guy that uh runs helps
run both of the shows
how was it being on the orville set
awesome
it's like you're walking around it's
almost like the starship enterprise
you're walking around like a spaceship
cause orville is like a funny star trek
right kind of thing
yeah anything by the way seth macfarlane
in my opinion
is one of the greatest comedy minds of
ever in history
i mean the amount of stuff this guy
makes is insane what a cool middle name
woodbury
woodbury mcfarland wow that's what did
family guy come out that was his big
cleveland
american dad by the way is unbelievable
like jay turned me on to it
right and i started watching it and now
i love it as much as family guy
cleveland's also great he's just really
fun you know what's so weird him and the
south park guy is always beefed over the
years like they don't like him
what they i think they like i don't want
to get this wrong but i think they think
like
he does easy comedy he doesn't i will
say this though i think the south park
guys are like gods too
so i really think they're really
important their work is important
because it's like they
are able to skewer any topic and bring a
little levity
to these hot button issues and like i
don't know i just i really think they're
geniuses but they do two different
things i respect them both
dude the south park guys are legit
geniuses they i think
actually are the best comedy minds yeah
of all time
truly i found it but seth mcfarlane does
not do easy comedy
seth macfarlane does is ted family guy
american dad cleveland show these are
fantastic shows i would say like even
out of
every single show any comedy animated or
not
family guy american dad those shows they
have the highest
chance that i'm actually going to laugh
out loud while i'm watching it
like it's it's a it's a no-brainer i i
don't love the early early earlies
anymore if you watch it you see how it
grew
but like i'll throw on any family guy at
any given moment and just start
understand also when he made family guy
dude he was only like 26 or 27 years old
so he grew
he's got to be worth like a billion
dollars uh recruited to hollywood he was
an animator and writer first for hannah
barbera i remember that
for several television series including
johnny bravo cow and chicken dexter's
laboratory i am weasel and larry and
steve
yeah this guy's had a phenomenal career
yeah i mean
yeah i see somebody who's three years
older than me i was gonna say guys
well you'll have to like look back and
say like okay so he made the family guy
when he was 26 years old
i'm 36 years old and i'm wearing a
carhartt jacket
you know what i mean like i feel like
that means when he was my age already he
was already
10 years into one of the most iconic
cartoons and animated shows of in
american history
um you ever just do that and then look
back and then you just feel worthless as
a person or
or you don't do that any like no because
you've accomplished so much in your life
in careers you always can do you always
feel like you can do it you always think
about like jesus when they had that
you know when that guy was my age he had
10 times as much big time because i
actually didn't
uh find really good fortune or good luck
until i was late uh later in age two
no what were you 35 when jokers came out
yeah but that's 35 is
you know almost 40. yeah you know what i
mean like 35 is
yeah you know like i don't know i mean
it could have not happened you know yeah
i was lucky but
ever tell you that i went to set to
mcfarland's house for a christmas party
[Laughter]
he has he has and this has been hey babe
where are we at we're at 50. we are uh
no he has he throws oh we really should
have ended it
you want to do it no no no we got to get
this that's not fair right because we're
not going to be meet again for
so long so he he has a christmas party
every year it's well known it's like one
of those ones was like
it's like the the the it party los
angeles or new york l.a okay
and um it's i mean he throws a bash
like the ones you see in like movies
like it's a black tie affair
right at his house beautiful home yeah i
mean i didn't see it all because it's
like
there's parts that were closed right but
when i tell you so like the
the the guy i know that's front that
turns to him he's like i'll come to the
party this year you know whatever like
let's go we fly out to la you and the
guys you and the other jokes yeah
yeah and we get to his house and uh it's
mayhem outside the house he has snow
it's snowing
in los angeles he gets a snow machine
it's snowing at his house there's snow
on the floor
there's a lot before you even walk in
there this was i think he changes it up
every year so this was the year i went
there was like snow globes actual snow
globes but made out of like plastic
on the front property in snow and you
got in them
and then like you there was a
professional photographer you took
pictures in the snow globe and
everything yeah and then you go to the
house you gotta get checked in
and then he had like i guess tennis
courts on the house in a dome
and so he takes the tennis courts out
and he makes that whole dome where the
tennis courts are
he puts in like carpeting and a stage
and couches
and it gets catered and it's this huge
room and there was a literal orchestra
like like when you go to like a jazz
like it was like a 20-piece orchestra
playing music everybody's in tuxedos
there's food there's a caviar being
passed around it's like you were told
you have to wear
black tie i i didn't i i decided to go
like i'm
like i was trying to be like hip and i
wore like a shirt and tie i think but i
didn't wear like i didn't i didn't have
a tux i was gonna
buy it though were you the only one
without a tux no no there was
it was various stages of dress but but i
would say the lion's share of people in
tuxedos and proper gowns like
wow ball gowns but it was still like a
rager
right like it was crazy like like like i
would sit down like ted dance and
we're sitting right next to me i'm like
oh my god it's ted dancing yeah and who
i later found out
uh his family watches the show amazing
and and knows the show can you believe
that that stuff blows my mind ted
danson's family watches the show ted
danson watching the show
ted danson has a and he's married to
mary steven and they have a shot named
charlie mcdowell's a friend of mine
he's visited set before and he's like oh
yeah they love the show and it's like we
found all that i know at the time i
wasn't going to bother him i had ted
danson sitting to my left i swear to god
christina aguilera sitting to my right i
would sit on the couch
alone i went so we went but i was i was
alone you know they got up to
and i just felt like really weird and i
just didn't say anything to anybody but
uh and then at one point and uh i guess
frank sinatra's
um sister na is it nancy i don't know
i don't know she gets up and she starts
singing and then said mcfarland do you
know this he sings on the show he's
singing
the the he sings the uh theme song but
he's he could have been a professional
singer
like he's phenomenal sings like sinatra
he's a crooner
it's unbelievable he actually has six
studio albums there you go
so he's the he was a freshman he's
performed as a singer at carnegie hall
and the royal albert hall in london
six studio albums in the same vein of
his musical idol frank sinatra beginning
with music is better than words in 2011.
everyone's been nominated for five
grammys
okay so i didn't even know that so
everyone's drinking dancing pushing each
other into the bushes
all that stuff we're having a great
rental time then he jumps up there the
big band starts he's sitting christmas
song he's singing sinatra classics
ted danson's there christina it was just
a wild party
then marilyn manson comes in right so oh
my god
so we at the end so we decided to leave
right but
myrrh stays and then murray goes and
sits down and tells me ladies sit down
and he was on a bench and it was one guy
in murray and marilyn manson and he said
marilyn manson was like i guess he was
like having a good time and everything
right and uh i'll tell you some stuff
off the air but then he
went patreon but then patreon then he
said marilyn manson i think he said he
went to one of the bedrooms they got all
the rolls of toilet paper
and then he went to the outside to the
edge and they were throwing they were
throwing toilet paper rolls off the off
the mountain
off the cliff of the cliff that he lived
on amazing so murray
was throwing toilet paper it was toilet
paper in the neighborhood with marilyn
manson
yeah so is the most epic party i've ever
been to in your whole life
uh yeah i didn't go crazy or anything
but just to be there and to see
you know who was there and to just it
was weird it was in his house it was a
really cool experience you know what i
mean like it's like
oh this is cool because everyone like
also was like invite only and i think
you had to be cool
so it wasn't like you were at like an
event right like behind
uh backstage at the grammys where it was
like still people had this security
people were just at the party right you
know what i mean so like what
would christina aguilera she's just
sitting there consciousness yeah so no
one with her
there's no nobody's no it's like so that
was kind of a cool
experience to just see people in their
element without
not worrying about people approaching
them it was just all love how long did
you stay at the party
um my guess three hours at least
okay three hours you had a good time you
drank you ate yeah yeah
snow machine it was really cool yeah and
then what do you do after that
that's the thing it's like when you go
to the party just go back to your hotel
yeah it is a weird it is
a weird thing because now you're like
now i'm just in an uber back to the
hotel
you get off stage you ever play like the
show of your life yeah it's like you
know
x amount of people you the place is
rocking you tore the house down
and then eight like eight minutes later
you're in this you're in
alone in the hotel room trying to order
like a quesadilla before room service
closes
and watching mario lopez well that's the
thing it's like when you like like like
shout out mary lopez when you like are
faint you know like famous you know
doing things like that
mo like you know you get a guy like a
drake or an adele or even a seth
mcfarlane
most of the day most of the time most of
their day most of their life is just
average joe schmoe stuff that we all do
it's just
little moments of their life that make
them unbelievable superstars like
drake is doing a sold out arena with the
flying bugatti through the thing
right that's only two hours of his day
right the rest of you woke up he brushed
his teeth he's sitting there on his
phone thinking about things to do yeah
he also
he also had to exfoliate at some point
yeah well he's just sitting in a car
trying to take a nap because they're in
traffic in the midtown tunnel that's
correct like so it's like sometimes i
think what people like oh
what it must be like to be famous it's
like most of your day is exactly the
same as it is wherever you are in your
life right now
just those people have a have a better
hour or two a day yeah they have an
inner circle that sees them at their
unless you become so famous or so out of
touch
that your life really becomes this
eccentric weird thing because some
people become that character
right they really do like you know even
us like we're here like all right like
we're we're doing the podcast but we're
moving and shaking we're trying to bang
off each other and make something
entertaining here yeah
yeah you know we even myself like you
know
it's not like this is exactly me but
like i'm also not always
just no just extra like this right you
know
i don't even speak english i just do it
for the podcast most of the time i speak
full i speak with a an irish bro
yeah but like unless you get like if
unless you just get into that person you
become like off the reservation
i think most people and that's something
that i was like
surprised and uh pleasant to find out
about people because i
once i got in the public and i had
access and got to meet other people like
that were
like either famous uh different levels
of fame and and
get to know some of those people it was
like refreshing to be like oh thank god
we're just all people
trying to figure this out it's just
normal people like some of the most
famous people i know
nervous you know like yeah because like
you know sometimes you get in a in
someone's
you know in in line with someone that's
like crazy famous
right and then you're even like oh i i
never know what to say to anybody yeah
yeah i know yeah you just kind of like
just the more normal you treat them the
more normally you get treated back 100
that's right that's what it is yeah yeah
well it's weird because no matter who
you are you do the same four things just
a nicer way
right yeah yeah that's what i'm saying
like
you know everybody no matter how famous
or not fame show everybody woke up today
brushed their teeth
thought about what was for breakfast and
then maybe some points of their day are
a little different like maybe some
people are going to
in office jobs that they don't like and
some people are going to you know
sell out freaking msg but really
it's just like the majority of the day
is the same and i don't get why people
like are so fascinated with celebrity
yeah i i mean i get maybe it's something
they have in common or something like
it's almost like music
you know like someone's art makes you
feel a certain way and then like so that
they mean more to you but
people put yeah so much celebrities on a
pedestal dude i never got either too
like when you're
when you're like on a set and you're
doing something
and then like if you're like uh a lead
in the show or
you know a post or whatever part big
part of the show and there's like a line
to get food they're like oh you cut the
line for the never
i would never every time that has ever
been offered to me i say
no immediately because i'm like not only
does does that in my opinion devalue the
others
it's also i'm the most replaceable all
i'm doing is saying words that somebody
else wrote
these guys the key grips and the camera
engineers went to school for it
if they decided to get up and walk away
we genuinely have no show
if i walked away they would just they
would just they could replace me with a
lesbian
you know and it'd be the same thing no
but it's true
i hate when they there's this thing for
people that like don't know
like on on sets or in in this industry
they'll call the actors or whatever
talent
yeah no so they they're like it's so
cringy i hate i remember when i first
saw that i'm like i don't know but but
that is like
industry lingo and completely acceptable
on every single set
tv there but i can't stand like where's
the talent that's for the talent that's
sort of talent i'm like
in on our show and they have never said
the word talent because you told them
don't do it
no no they they i mean literally it's
so even everyone they go on said they do
it the other way they're like
coming on set now the impractical
jerk-offs
we might have gone too far the other way
dude i have actual i have actual
uh uh video i have actual video
and photographic proof of who killed
princess diana this has been hey vape
don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey